here's another type of quadrilateral
let's name it ABCD in this quadrilateral
both pairs of opposite sides are
parallel the first pair of opposite
sides is a b and d c we can see that a b
is parallel to DC we use two arrows in
the same direction to show that the
sides are parallel the second pair of
opposite sides is ad and BC we can also
see that ad is parallel to BC so we draw
arrows like this such quadrilaterals are
called parallelograms both pairs of
opposite sides are parallel this was the
basic property of a parallelogram in a
parallelogram the opposite sides are
also equal this side will be equal to
this side we can say that a B is equal
to DC this side will be equal to this
side ad is equal to BC and guess what in
a parallelogram the opposite angles are
also equal opposite angles are angles
which do not have a common side this
angle will be equal to this angle angle
da B is equal to angle D CB and this
angle will be equal to this angle angle
ABC is equal to angle ADC remember this
is the basic property of a parallelogram
the opposite sides as well as the
opposite angles are equal let's see a
special case of a parallelogram in this
parallelogram all the sides are equal to
each other this is a rhombus so a
rhombus is a parallelogram with all its
sides equal it will have all the
properties of a parallelogram as well as
this additional property that all its
sites will be equal there is another
special case of a parallelogram let me
draw it on a new page
remember the opposite sides have to be
parallel it is a quadrilateral drawn
like this the opposite sides of this
quadrilateral are parallel so it is a
parallelogram let's name the
quadrilateral ABCD why is it special all
the angles in the quadrilaterals are
right angles this special case of
parallelogram is called a rectangle this
is how a rectangle can be defined it is
a parallelogram with all angles being
right angles just like in a
parallelogram the opposite sides of a
rectangle are equal this side will be
equal to this side and this side will be
equal to this one now it gets even more
interesting this quadrilateral is a
special case of a rectangle let's call
it PQRS like the rectangle all its
angles are right angles but it has an
additional property all its sides are
equal to each other this type of
quadrilateral is called a square
basically it is a rectangle with all its
sites equal the rectangle is the special
case of the parallelogram and this
square is a special case of a rectangle
but weight in a square the opposite
sides are parallel so it is a
parallelogram all its sides are also
equal so it's also a rhombus again what
is a rhombus it is a quadrilateral with
all its sides equal and opposite sides
parallel to each other but how is the
square different from a normal rhombus
it is a rhombus in which all angles are
right angles next we will review all the
types of quadrilaterals and how they are
related to each other
you
you